you as promised president biden did not
bring up the impeachment trial today
instead
making his first visit to the pentagon
as commander-in-chief
promising to keep an eye on china while
also making sure to recognize
the space force white house
correspondent peter ducey was along for
the short ride across the potomac
the new president is laying out a new
foreign policy
as your commander-in-chief i will never
hesitate to use force to defend the
vital interests of america the american
people
but i believe force should be a tool of
last resort not first
and just before motorcading to the
pentagon president biden showed the kind
of power he wants to use
while addressing the military coup in
burma the military must relinquish power
first steps to try to make that happen
are financial
the us government is taking steps to
prevent the generals from improperly
having access to the one billion dollars
in burmese government funds held in the
united states
following a lengthy meeting with
military officials about what the u.s
can do
the president appeared to give a shout
out to the space force we need to take
on the dangers and opportunities of
emerging technologies
enhance our capabilities in cyber space
ensure that we are positioned to lead a
new era of competition
from the deep sea to outer space but at
home covet 19 concerns remain issue
number one as the white house warns
parents
a majority of students back to school
within a hundred days might just mean
one day a week
when president biden talked for the last
couple months particularly during the
transition about
reopening schools within the first 100
days why didn't he ever mention the
small print
that that was just going to be for one
day a week as the goal well
again the president made uh set a goal
of reopening the majority of schools uh
within a hundred days and when you asked
what that meant i answered the question
so uh we are uh that is the that is not
the
ceiling that is the uh that is the bar
we're trying to leap over
and exceed the president is convening a
new task force to possibly confront
china
the task force will work quickly drawing
on civilian and military experts across
the department
and in a brief exchange with fox news
the president didn't rule out a
retroactive punishment
mr president any interest in punishing
china for not being truthful about kobed
last year
[Music]
the president isn't describing china as
a threat he is instead talking about the
china
challenge bloomberg is reporting that
tonight will be president biden's first
phone call with china's president xi
and that would be just a few hours after
he told me there that he is interested
in getting information about china
maybe not telling the truth concerning
kovid last year right
peter ducey live on the north lawn peter
thank you now back to the